[Music]
ces is sort of like a treasure hunt and
even though this year's show is scaled
back a bit there are still plenty of
opportunities to find fun gadgets like
this a bluetooth speaker that
magnetically attaches to the back of
your smartphone here are some of the
other unique things i found
ces 2022 a show some thought wouldn't
happen at all we have a bubble around
ces which is not impermeable but it's
really really good vaccinations and
masks are required kovit tests are free
and i think we're at the stage of having
to learn to live with this where we have
to go forward we have to set the example
for the world some media and exhibitors
did pull out but there's still plenty to
see
[Applause]
i mean i have to hop on the world's
first electric snowmobile moonbike's
electric sled weighs less than 200
pounds goes 26 miles an hour and runs
for an hour and a half once you push
that button you get that immediate
torque and it's just really really
playful really fun so this is a shingle
where the solar is built right into it
and you nail it to your roof just like
you would a standard shingle gaf
timberline solar shingles are about half
the cost of teslas my expectations in
maybe five to ten years from now
putting a solar roof will be just no
brainer bob is the world's smallest
dishwasher and it only uses one gallon
of water the mini machine perfect for
apartments and requires no hookups plug
it to the electrical network fill it
here like a coffee machine with one
gallon of water and it cleans in 20
minutes three hundred dollars on
pre-order this stuffed animal nibbles on
your finger it's called amagami ham and
it's basically
provides healing effects just like
babies or little animals do when they
nibble on your finger soothing unique
but also kind of weird a little odd a
little odd
finally meet the king of massage chairs
body friends pharaoh o2 here we go oh
now it's starting i feel it it's oh wow
premium speakers voice control and a
burst of oxygen to relax and rejuvenate
but before you get too comfy keep in
mind it's ten thousand dollars you just
take this and i'll be done for the rest
of the day thank you see you later see
yet